boozy serious bring that to Brooklyn
white people from all over will be like
oh my gosh oh my god you better leave
this out the video hey guys my name is
ELISA I'm from Texas and where I come
from we like to enjoy some busy cereal
so I asked around the office if anybody
has tried it and no one seems to know
what I'm talking about so I'm gonna let
them know how we do it in the South the
only thing is they don't know what's
coming
Spyke milk like are we getting drunk
they're not even 11 o'clock
Bon Appetit
I don't know it tastes kind of like
regular milk to me which is gonna be
weird and despite to the lot of us often
them back.one now there's like that
tastes like vodka like there's this
light aftertaste of alcohol but it's not
upsetting me like it's not gonna stop me
from going through this whole bowl right
now so the classiest one does have all
of them you can find me on Twitter at I
am disgusted because I'm I feel like
this is great for Spring Break with your
friends like oh we're gonna be day
drinking so let's turn up with some
drunk cereal
this is milk I'm really bad at tasting
booze in milk like I think this is why
White Russians became a thing it's cuz
it yeah it's hidden this tastes like
dinner like roasted chicken and like
rice and peas in string beans are you
good are you sure yeah I usually think
alcohol ruins things yes so surprised
maybe it's just like you put the right
amount in oh it tastes like ham and
collard green this is really good this
is like hashtag adulting i don't know if
it's because I'm excited but I kind of
feel drunk already at night
as soon as five o'clock hits event like
this right now I can't do that I can't
taste anything besides cinnamon toast
crunch oh yeah that's a good thing no
honey Jack and French toasts that's like
a match made in heaven you know we these
are no longer the breakfast of champions
junction and toast crunch I would eat
this on the beach dominant yeah in my
finery just like this and a speedo see I
really want to throw a breakfast party
now where I invite my friends over we
watch crappy cartoons and get drunk off
cereal and just just have fun these
cereals they're great I love breakfast I
love these breakfast booth cereal milk
love it that's all awesome I do feel it
mm-hmm here right now next time I go to
the club this is what I'm gonna bring
you just need to put your milk in the
flask you get a drink at the bar
you have your cereal in your pocket and
you just put it together on the floor
can't wait for my other meetings a day
[Music]